so quick joke to start the video why did
Godzilla have a bad stomach because he
swallowed a bunch of semen now welcome
to the heavy spoilers show I'm your
house definition a que god spoiler and
this episode were breaking down some
amazing details that we know about the
upcoming Monster Mash of the Titans
there may be some spoilers here so if
you don't anything ruined then I
recommend that you go deeper underground
as we will be talking in depth about
some of the best aspects of the upcoming
film make sure you smash that like
button if you enjoy the video and please
subscribe to the channel to never miss
an update without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
breakdown ok so if you haven't seen our
last video then go and check that out
now as it sort of fills in some of the
groundwork for this one if you're pretty
much up to speed with all of the plot
leaks in the film then this will be
going over them in more detail at thanks
to friend of the show Ian Cassidy who
dropped a ton of info on the project and
pretty much went over how everything was
gonna work top to bottom we've also
integrated some new details and a
potential trailer release stage so yeah
definitely stick around till the end and
take these with a pinch of salt as we
have cause can't verify them until we
see the movie for ourselves but from
what we've heard of insiders they all
line up and flash out the world in a
really interesting way I think when you
hear them you'll probably agree that
they sound legit off what we know and
you know what the channel we do our full
research before posting to make sure
there's no mistakes now in the leaks
last time we learned that Mechagodzilla
was going to be made using the brains of
the Ghidorah head that we seen at the
end of king of the monsters this was
being worked on by a company called apex
and Ian ended up going into more detail
on these and what it is that they're up
to so according to Ian apex makes
biological weapons that are designed to
eradicate the Titans with the help of
Titan DNA from Godzilla and Ghidorah
they make a WMD called khayru that can
wipe it both Godzilla and Kong off the
face of the earth apex has two agendas
disrupt the natural order and force the
two Kings into battle where they can
then strike on the loser with
who as I'm sure you guessed is actually
Mechagodzilla no no prices forgetting
that right okay now mechagodzilla's role
is important but apparently it doesn't
appear a lot instead of being used as a
way to manipulate the other characters
monarch are trying to do everything that
they can to stop apex so they begin to
research the Hollow Earth which is where
Kong roams and rules over it turns out
that the main passages of the Hollow
Earth run through Skull Island
which is how Kong was able to migrate
into ruling over the domain so easily
the Titans have all moved there and they
show up on Skull Island to falling under
the rule of Kong now during the research
into Hollow Earth we discover the
origins of Kong and the Gojira species
the two bloodlines hated each other but
we discovered that Godzilla is actually
the last of its kind
he lasted so long because he was a super
species of Gojira their alpha that ruled
over them before Ghidorah 's arrival
juxtaposing this the Kong species
evolved differently due to being
primates the Alpha Kong was known as the
king of all Kong's and king of Skull
Island would you cause paints out how
things were at the location their home
is off-limits to the Gojira and they've
kept them out due to the storms that
surround the island
Godzilla is unaware of the Hollow Earth
tunnels but he later discovers them now
we discover that when the Hollow Earth
was formed it broke the planet up into
continents and also enabled there to be
different civilizations
Godzilla's home became the lost city of
Atlantis whereas Skull Island became
well Skull Island again no prizes
forgetting that right now the
inhabitants of Skull Island believed
that one day there would be a reckoning
when Godzilla would arrive on the island
and Kong their protector would go
head-to-head with it this is shown on a
cave painting that has predicted that
Godzilla will come for a day of
reckoning when he feels that his rule is
no longer valid this is a threat to what
he uses the natural order and it will
cause a lot of issues and thus apex have
manipulated the situation to make it
seem like this is the time as we said
the battle has been prophesized and the
people of the island have prepared for
this day over the centuries by building
a giant axe for Kong
we have confirmed by the toy leaks now
Mechagodzilla has an orca device built
into it which causes a lot of issues
with the Titans Godzilla will become
confused over why they aren't falling in
line and he becomes violent and angry
over no longer being the boss as Kong is
the one Titan that can't actually be
controlled blame falls at his feet and
thus the to end up on a collision course
now as with most face offs you need
motivation on both sides so that you
know like the characters they really
have a reason to fight you can't just
kidnap Kong's ma then and make them
fight Godzilla you need a proper reason
here an apex a flood Skull Island with a
lot of seismic activity these
earthquakes massively mess up the
landscape and make Kong believe that he
has to stop Godzilla from destroying his
home even further with the island on the
verge of collapse
Kong seeks out Godzilla and the movie
apparently takes the POV of four
perspectives that is con Godzilla the
lovely the lovely people are apex and
those at monarch that are trying to stop
them but we want to see them fight we
don't want any more delays we'll want to
see them fight you got it now this leads
to a battle in Hong Kong that Ian
confirmed will be 5 minutes without
cutting away from Godzilla or Kong this
is great as it means no humans
scrambling around in the rubble with a
fight going on in the background and
it's gonna be very visceral in your face
you big disgrace slapping a Kong all
over the place now one of the big points
of contention circulating around the
movie is that there's no way Kong will
actually be equal to Godzilla
however Ian states that this will prove
he's an equal and a Titan that can
easily stand toe-to-toe with him Ian
says that the studio now Kong is bigger
with casual fans and thus they will
really be pushing him as much as the
king of the monsters he's also a primate
so in some ways is closer to us and a
big lizard and the men to be leaning
heavily into this in order for the
audience to gain a new respect for Kong
the battle ends with Mechagodzilla
arriving and the pair will go against it
we did say that we had heard that could
potentially be a death in this situation
however Ian stated that there isn't and
in fact they will both survive the
encounter this will lead to the pair
gain
new titles are their names and they will
roam different parts of the earth
Godzilla will gain the name king of the
monsters and Earth's guardian
whereas Kong will be the god of Skull
Island and protector of Hollow Earth
apparently he will also also yet
apparently get his King Kong title too
now they've pretty much stripped the
character of the King from his name and
this is seen in the title for this movie
and of course Kong Skull Island this
movie is called Godzilla where's Kong
where as at the end of it apparently he
will indeed have the full title King
Kong and thus this will bring everything
full circle and set up a brand new
monster universe that legendary can use
to branch off all of their creatures
into yeah lots of things to look forward
to and after reading all this I'm very
very excited now before we get into the
rest of the video I just wanna let you
know we're giving away another free copy
of the MCU infinity saga box set to one
random subscriber it was so popular last
time I decided to do it again so yeah
best of luck to everyone who takes part
now as always the winners gonna be
chosen on the 15th of August and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts in
the updates in the comment section below
I really hope that you in it yes you and
thanks for all the support now as for
the trailer release date this rumor
comes from Godzilla movies calm and
they've stayed that the first look at
the film will debut on July 31st
according to the website the footage is
reportedly being attached to Warner
Brothers the article rerelease of
Christopher Nolan's inception which will
be hitting theaters again starting July
31st the date was originally meant to be
the 17th
however due to Tanabe push back to the
trailer was as well now this report
states that Warner Brothers are trying
to entice moviegoers to venture back to
that theatre once more following a near
five-month lockdown caused by the corona
virus this pretty much saw every theater
shut down completely for the entirety of
spring and most of summer and it's only
recently that businesses have start
operating again with movie theaters
being one of them the footage was
expected to be shown at Comic Con this
year but again this was another of
that was cancelled due to kovat
according to the report in addition to
Godzilla vs. Kong the inception
re-release will also debut new footage
from Wonder Woman 1984 and a fresh look
at the new dune movie so yeah lots of
info there and if you want to read the
full report then I'll leave it linked in
the description so you can check the
entire thing out
anyway that's everything you need to
know about the movie and all the new
details that we have if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and if you missed our breakdown last
time then make sure you check it out
right after this if you want to support
the channel from as little as night you
know in cents a month then please click
the join button below
we massively appreciate you and it's a
thank you you get access to content
early we want to come chat except for
the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the discord link of
the description below anyway that's the
video over hope you have a great day in
that ya house hold did you say you you
mate was that what well I think I hear
my mom calling for my tea so I've got to
go but I'll speak to you next time take
care
I love you I love you
[Music]
you